I'm going to talk about
libraries for learning with sequence
data hmm and so I work at Mount Sinai
Medical School I'm in the hammer lab
which is this collection of people here
and a few others and so we are not
biologists we work kind of in close
cooperation with different biomedical
research groups we work with a vaccine
Cora Mount Sinai we work with some
clinicians and the sort of conceit of
the lab is that we are trying to
leverage computer science and places
where it's particularly useful for
biomedicine so we try to find
collaborations where the missing
ingredient is machine learning or
managing a large collection of data or
there's already domain expertise so we
can hook into and learn from but we're
going to sort of add a lot of value by
being present so those are we've been
going for about two years and we found
some of the good collaborations in Mount
Sinai and I'm going to talk about some
of our applications that we work on and
how that connects to deep learning over
sequences so the motivation for me
getting started with this is that we are
working on different projects related to
cancer immunotherapy and so this is kind
of an I don't know if you guys have paid
attention to this but it's a
increasingly hot field is very promising
collection of therapies some of which
are personalized some of which are
generic but they all involve using
patient immune elements the immune
system of a patient to in some way
attack a cancer in that patients body so
examples of these the ones that are sort
of better developed and more successful
our modulators of the immune system that
make the immune system more aggressive
and then cause it to attack cancer cells
and then sort of more interesting
experimental kinds of treatments involve
crafting personalized vaccines based on
the mutational profile of a cancer and
that's a lot of we've been working on is
an
second category but even in the better
established therapies there are a lot of
questions around what exactly are the
immune cells in a patient's body
recognizing is it possible to predict
what an immune system is responding to
from the mutated protein content of a
cancer and so that actually raises a lot
of machine learning problems actually a
kind of well-posed machine learning
problems out of what sounds like a
really messy field like I think that
cancer medical research is tremendously
messy and immunology is really
complicated and messy and it didn't seem
like the intersection of those two
things would give you nice problems but
it actually does which has been nice for
me as someone getting started with
cancer immunology with machine learning
background the problems often pop out
that are easy to condense into a data
set so that you can learn over so one
particular problem of interest is if we
know the mutated proteins and a
particular cancer can we predict which
fragments of those are going to be
recognizable by the immune system so
this sort of boils down to a regression
task over short sequences so proteins
made out of lots of amino acids and
we're looking at fragments little short
sequences those amino acids and we want
to predict different properties of those
sequences so the most interesting one
for us is whether or not one of these
protein fragments is going to stick to a
thing called an MHC which kind of looks
like a like a catcher's mitt that holds
up a little piece of a protein and
sticks it on the surface of a cell and
then t-cells come looking around and
scavenging the surface of cancer cells
and if they have been trained to look
for a particular pattern they will kill
that cell and it's super cool to watch
in video and it's sometimes can make for
really effective therapies and so it's
really important to know which protein
fragments are going to be immune
recognizable and luckily immunologists
have been working for a couple decades
now to assemble good datasets on
these basic interactions so isolate the
parts of the recognition process that we
can quantify take different fragments of
proteins and put them together with
different MH sees these little
presentation platforms and we have
hundreds of thousands of examples of how
well different fragments stick to
different little catcher's mitts I wish
I had a diagram the MHC to show you guys
so that's the motivation fry got started
with working with neural networks and
deep networks and recurrent neural
networks for immunological applications
and so one thing that jumps out of this
problem is that there are certain kinds
of prediction tasks where the range of
sequence lengths are actually quite
small so there's certain molecules that
have very strict profiles they almost
always want to stick to things that are
nine amino acids long and sometimes
eight or ten but it's very constrained
and so if you're working with sequences
that actually don't very much in length
they're almost always nine characters
long then you're not really working with
sequences so very often you can get away
with just transforming those into some
vector space and it becomes another
generic machine learning problems this
is a diagram of one of the predictors
I've been working on and and it starts
with a amino acid sequence and then Maps
it into so there's just a vector
embedding of each amino acid and so you
get this vector space that's the
embedding size 64 times this fixed
length which is nine so you get a fixed
vector per string and you're not really
dealing with sequence data anymore is
that the source of the mysterious echo
all right and so if you get a little bit
of deviation from those links you can
often find ways to reduce your sequences
down to the lengths for which you have a
lot of data so for the if you have
mostly length nine sequences and a few
length eight you can maybe find some
reduction like can you take out middle
elements of the sequences
and reduce all the 9s to eights or vice
versa can you stick stuff in there's a
lot of these like tricks that if you
have a lot of sequence data of the same
length you probably will have the most
success making a fixed vector space
representation and finding some way to
stick the stragglers into the same
representation so we've had a lot of
success of that other group set a lot of
success with that so I think if you're
doing sequence learning it gets
interesting once you have varying length
sequences so you're really true sequence
data in the sense that you you know you
might be learning over a corpus of text
or full sequences of proteins or
something where there's not one fixed
simple vector representation to describe
each sequence and so there's traditional
approaches to dealing with these kinds
of datasets so by far the most common is
just 2d tempura lies the data find some
way to count up occurrences so bag of
words or Engram models where you take
your sequential data and say well count
up how many times this pattern happens
and get a collection of patterns and and
you sort of take things out of their
sequential context and often for things
like topic model angers really where all
you just care about is how often things
are coming up that's good enough and you
and you lose the temporal dependency in
the data and that actually helps you
build better models because maybe that
temporal dependency never mattered in
the first place so another thing that
people do so I spent a very strange
summer working in finance and making
currency price predictors and a lot of
the features that I was making and once
I was using from other people were these
like weird sliding window features so
look at sliding windows over different
time scales and then find ways to sort
of craft lots of descriptors to try to
summarize everything that's happening up
to this point in time or around this
point in time and so there's like a
whole cottage industry of making these
weird little descriptors but it's all
manual tweaking and
I don't know it's not really like a
generalizable technique it's like a
thing that for some problems you can you
can get it to work and then there's sort
of more sophisticated techniques for
dealing with sequence data so
conditional random fields and Markov
random fields and various probabilistic
models that that work for specific tasks
but are kind of non composable in the
sense that you can't just use CRFs
generically often if you get a CRF
working for a new kind of task you just
that's a publishable element because for
a new task inference was probably really
hard so you have to find some new
approximation and it's not it lacks that
sort of building block quality than
neural networks have and so this is huge
boom and deep learning around
essentially they're how modular and
composable the ideas are you can take
convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks and stick them
together and get captioning models which
is the thing that's harder to do if you
work with more rigorous things like
probabilistic models
okay so I've explained why varying
lengths sequences are hard and why
existing approaches have some limits so
let's look at some things you can do
within the neural network space and so
the simplest thing you can do is you
just take a neural network that you feed
it one sequence elements at a time and
some vector representation and you loop
back onto that same model its output
from the previous time step so you give
it a character it creates an output you
give it another character it creates an
output based on the last output and the
current character so this is a simple
recurrent neural network so the
recurrence is that flow of the previous
output as an input to the next state and
so these models have actually been
around for a really long time and they
work in certain cases so in cases where
you have very short-range dependencies
between the inputs and the output that
you want to see so if you're if you have
some continuously labeled sequence where
the event of interest happens within a
few time steps of some particular input
then a simple recurrent neural network
can cap
and so that is a nice extension you take
whatever neural network you want and
just loop its output back into itself
that works okay for some circumstances
it didn't really work in general which
is why these didn't take off and so the
problems with simple recurrent neural
networks are centered around what
happens when you get very long sequences
so if you have a sequence of a hundred
or a thousand time steps and you're
trying to connect that a particular
input a thousand time steps ago is
related to something that you need to
identify now that's very hard because
they typically the the activation
function in these neural networks is
some nonlinear squishing so you go
through a thousand steps of matrix
multiply squish matrix multiplies squish
squish squish-squish and then you end up
with very very faded signal from many
time steps ago so it's a the presence of
anything that happens in the far past is
an infinitesimal part of what you have
in your current state and your home
memory in a simple neural network is
just the current state the current
output and so this also when you when
you try to chain back words through the
the series of of activations to train
the neural network so when you do back
propagation because you're the the
effects of anything in the past vanishes
your gradients can also vanish and then
you also have the possible compounding
of if you apply function over and over
again and it has and it's growing a
little bit each time you can get
exploding gradient so your gradients can
can have norms they become sort of in
feasibly large that you can't learn
anymore so so a simple recurrent neural
network is not really appropriate for
anything other than very well
constrained sequence problems short
sequences preferably with continuous
labeling where every time point you have
an output and very short delays between
the some event happening in the input
space and some output that you want to
see so a key innovation in getting recur
note no
to work more generally actually happen a
really long time ago so it's this thing
called the LS TM the long short-term
memory I think and so the the first
papers on the LS TM came out in the 90s
and they had a really neat innovation
that so it was somewhat ahead of its
time and that it's a model that works in
general but is fairly expensive and the
initial paper evaluates having nodes
with like two LST M's trying to learn
very synthetic grammars and they take
like 20 hours to Train on someone's 486
and and so this entire family of models
was revolutionary but really not
recognized for a long time until we had
more computational capacity and so what
is cool about the LST M and there's
other neural networks that have come
since then that sort of exploit the same
key feature is they have a notion of
gating so the the propagation of state
from one step to another is sort of
adaptively gated it can turn on and off
depending on the current state and the
current input the the influence of the
of the input in the previous state is
not just a this so in as simple RNN you
have just the same mapping applied over
and over again you have your previous
state and the current input and then you
get another state so in this case the
default behavior just a propagates state
between time steps so they if really if
your if your input is somehow
uninformative you can just imagine this
is just copying its state from time step
to time step forward forever and then
there's a adaptive update to the state
to this internal state which is
different than the output coming out of
the node so this internal state is sort
of adaptively you transform your input
in the last state into a sort of
hypothesis so here's how I'd like to
update my hidden state and then there's
additionally at the bottom the little
forget gate is also adaptively telling
like how much of my previous state do I
want to
hold onto so there's the sort of
manipulation of memory is much more
parameter izybelle instead of having the
same deterministic mapping of your new
memory is a fixed function of your of
your old memory instead you get these
sort of degrees of freedom parameters
you can tweak the both crafty input into
a proposal for a new state and also
focus on when should you discard your
old state versus hold on to it and so
this is a much more powerful model it's
really sort of a you can think of it as
like a continue eyes automaton it's a
like a computational element you can
implement simple algorithms with it
but it has continuous parameters that
you can learn through back propagation
I'm going to pause there just to make
sure if people are with me so let's have
maybe like a open for questions moment
so so it's a it's a vector and you
initialize it typically to zero and then
you update it based on the on its
previous value and the current inputs
and then the the output of this node
goes up to deeper parts of the neural
network so there's sort of a separation
relative to the simpler network I showed
before there's a difference now between
the internal memory of this RNN unit of
a layer and the output that it shows to
deeper parts of the network
other questions
it works perfectly fine with variable
length sequences there's implementation
li sometimes people try to stuff the
input representation to be all fixed
length so maybe make vectors of length
200 and then you have to mask out the
ones that are missing to accommodate
varying length sequences but that's
really kind of an affordance for when
you do stuff on the GPU it's often
easier to have instead of a collection
of strings just to make a big matrix but
as far as the learning algorithm it
really works over arbitrary length
sequences there are some questions about
how far back through time do you want to
try to back propagate so there's there's
an efficiency issue if you're if you're
learning something that you know reads
an entire book and then emits a yes or
no answer for so you need a really big
data set but also the you know there
might be some diminishing utility to
scanning through the whole book and then
back propagating all the way back
through the whole book you might
actually want it just to scan through
most of the book until near the end and
then it'll have a little summary vector
its internal state will summarize we'll
have read and then you can do some steps
of back propagation towards the end so
there's there are questions of how
truncated should back propagation be
going backwards in time but the the
model itself will just for every new
token of your sequence is going to
update its internal state and emit a new
output and you give it another token and
it updates its internal state and emits
a new output and it does that for any
length sequence and you can generate
infinite text that way you can read
infinite text that way
so you typically don't want to use an
are down unless you sort of know that
your situation is well suited for it so
they're you know if you're doing time
series regression and you and and you
have good labeling they're trying to
predict one time series for another then
it's possible that an RNN is well suited
because you have close correspondence
between what happens in one series to
another it's sort of densely fills in
the labels but I think for most tasks if
you have enough data it's preferable to
use some gated model so I'm showing the
lsdm because I thought I'd be
overwhelming to show lots of models but
there's there's another one called the
GRU the gated recurrent unit that's also
kind of interchangeable and there's some
other more experimental models have been
proposed but they all have the same
quality and that they have some sort of
gating between zero and one usually it's
a sigmoid so it's like sort of you
imagine you had like an on/off switch
and you try to make it continuous so you
made just adaptive sigmoid function that
is switching how much you're updating
your state so it gives it some control
over when it should update the state
versus just keep propagating it forward
so if you have enough data to train
those kinds of models you need more data
because that more parameters then you
should probably use that kind of model
and so the rough rules of thumb are that
you for I know a largest two layer LS TM
you might want like a megabyte of text
and that's like very generic it's like
you know like what does that mean and it
there's lots of different domains
whether like that means different things
but that's sort of roughly to scale you
want like you're not going to be able to
Train one of these models off of a you
know single email
right okay so part no there's no white
forwarding required so part of the power
of these models is that the output
coming from an LS TM layer is not
necessarily the thing you're trying to
label it's just some other vector
representation so as you feed in inputs
you get a sequence of these output
vectors so you could be feeding in
characters and you get back thousand
dimensional output vectors which
themselves can now be inputs to another
lsdm and that lsdm can also output
vectors those could be 100 dimensional
and then eventually you get to a place
where you really just want to take four
it depends on the task but a common
thing you do is you take the last time
steps output vector as sort of a summary
of everything that's happened so you can
imagine reading a sentence and it goes
through a four-layer else TM and then
your summary of the meaning of that
sentence will be the last layers last
output and that's sort of a basis for a
simple machine translation model because
then you can take that meaning vector
and use another lsdm to decode it into a
different language so the there's a
certain degree of summarization that's
happening as you progress through a
sequence
exactly yeah
anymore okay all right so let's go on
alright so just in case you weren't
intimidated by the last diagram here are
the actual update equations and so the
things that are just worth noting here
is so I I don't think I've labeled this
really sufficiently but so this is the
forget gate and just the thing to like
if it's a bunch of gibberish unless you
look at it a couple times but just
notice that it's being squished with a
sigmoid continuous function between 0 &
1 and so you can think of anywhere you
see a sigmoid you could think of it as
sort of we wanted some sort of binary
switch but we can't learn binary logic
from examples so instead we put a
sigmoid in there because it's sort of
the softened version of just a binary
threshold so in the places where you see
sigmoid you can think of those as places
where you wanted just binary switches
but couldn't have them and then these
ten H's are sort of transformations
between negative 1 to +1 and those are
those are kind of like the information
we want to store so we want two things
that we want to keep as either internal
state or output to the next layer we're
going to squish to be between negative 1
and +1 and things that are supposed to
be binary switches where sigmoid and
then all these parameters all these W
matrices are different parameters within
a single layer of an LS TM that you
learn through back propagation it's yeah
it's a continuous value between negative
1 to +1 so there's sort of like units of
memory or outputs that someone else will
use someone else being another layer and
the sigmoids are kind of things that we
wanted to treat as binary switches but
needed to make it soft
so C sub T is the internal stage the
hidden memory of an LST M unit a time
step T and so you can look at the the
update for the internal state is a
function of how much of it you should
remember which is this forget gate F T
so if the if F T is high then you
remember a lot of your previous state
and if F T is low then you forget it
entirely and then there's another switch
another continue eyes on/off switch of
how much of your input should you look
at that I Sub T is is this an important
input and then there's some
transformation of the input and the
previous output to make a hypothesis of
here's the kind of hidden state that we
could generate from the current time
step so this is the kind of a proposal
of this would be the kind of update I
would make to your hidden state of this
time step but I might not apply much of
it because I T will be low and I might
want to keep most of my previous memory
or conversely if you hit so if you're
doing language modeling you hit a period
you'll find that F T often will be very
low so at the end of a sentence you just
want to clear your state forget it
and the weight you afford to the input
will be very high so this is a way to
sort of switch between how much of my
input do I care about versus how much of
my previous state do I care about for
which one
why am I not Reece quitting it I'm not
really sure that's a good question I'm
just going to looked at it and looked
like a typo but I got it out of Alex
graves is Alex graves as a researcher
works on this so I'm trusting him on
this being right but it does look
strange to not squish it I kind of feel
like there should be a 10 H around the
whole thing is there
there is in going to the output but not
for CT itself so H sub T is the output
going to the next layer it's okay it's a
very technical detail I just want to
give a general flavor of the kind of
logic so you have these like 10 H parts
that are trying to map into bits of
information and you have these sigmoid
parts that are trying to turn things on
or off okay so I started with this very
heavy duty motivating example which is
predicting whether peptides stick to
certain proteins for cancer
immunotherapy I was going to show more
of that work but I thought it might kind
of go over people's heads I don't know
if it's that accessible so instead I
made a character level language model
for generating fairytales excite you
guys might enjoy that more so the source
data downloaded Grimm's fairy tales from
Project Gutenberg which is it's about
500,000 characters 69 of which are
distinct so here's an example I think
from the beginning as a certain King had
a beautiful garden and in the garden
stood a tree and it's very repetitive
style of text so I thought this actually
be easy to learn with a recurrent neural
network and so the the specific the
specific task that I'm using an RNN for
here is is language modeling this is
actually like one of the easier ways to
train a recurrent neural network because
you always have a label you're not
dealing with sometimes you have tasks
where you have really long sequence and
then a label at the end and that's
harder in this case you have every fixed
number of characters you ask it to
predict the next character and then you
can penalize how wrong it was about what
the next character is so it's sort of
like an easy RN task it's a gimme and so
the the input in this case is I make a
hot shot encoding of every character
it's a 69 length vector one of whose
elements is 1 and then the output is a
probability distribution so softmax
layer which creates a probable
distribution over possible next
characters
and I'm penalizing it for all the
probabilities of the signs that aren't
on the correct next character and so I
wanted to show a couple different
implementations I started with Karis
because it's what I'm using for other
learning tasks and I think it has a very
nice API so Karis is inspired by torch
which is so how many people in this room
know Yama Khun a good fraction so Yuans
lab uses this library called torch I
mean they made it and they also use it
and it's a very nice neural network API
for Lua and everything's great about it
except that it's in Lua and so I think
that people were sort of jealous of the
stuff that the Facebook AI lab could do
with it and so there have been a couple
efforts to bring it over to Python and
Karis designing the the most successful
torch inspired machine learning library
so it has a pretty clean API and it has
a lot of components you want to use so
I'm going to recommend this is if you
just want to get started with deep
learning or recurrent neural networks I
would highly recommend doing things with
Kerris because it typically just sort of
works straight out the gate and so
there's like a few things worth
emphasizing here so I have a layer sizes
list which just has how big all the
layers should be and I'm making a
stacked lsdm in this case I just use two
layers both of which were size 256 and
the first one needs to return all of its
outputs at every time steps this returns
sequences equals true means at every
single time step you should emit an
output so you make a sequence of outputs
which is then getting fed into those
looks totally weird this only works
because there's two of them I just
noticed because they should all return
sequences equals true except for the
last one whatever so this is emitting an
output vector per input character and
then there's a last LS TM layer which is
not returning its full sequence of
outputs just returning a single last
output and that is going into a softmax
layer
which gives you a probability
distribution over 69 characters and then
train with rmsprop which is a really
good default sort of adaptive stochastic
gradient descent it's a little more
stable than just regular gradient
descent and then the penalty there at
the bottom you just say I want
categorical cross entropy and it does
the right thing and makes a optimizer
for you so I think it's a very clean API
it's easy to play with it's a little bit
tedious if you want to do something new
so if you want to make a new kind of
model so you have some improvement over
the ellis TM that you want to implement
the the sort of effort curve from using
existing components and other people
have implemented to making a new Kerris
component is extremely high in my
opinion and it's very easy to break
things and the internal api of karas is
a mess but the external API i'm karis is
awesome
so i also made an implementation in
lasagne which is bigger so lasagna is a
much more so Karis really hides its
under the hood components caris works as
a wrapper around theano but it's a very
thick wrapper it protects you from
Theano you don't have to worry about
mysterious errors and who here is used
Theano
good number of people I actually hate
using Theon oh I got these totally
confusing tensor 544 is not the shape of
10 2 or 3,000 errors and just I always
like get stuck debugging this like you
know simple line of code that I have no
idea what's going wrong because Theano
is entirely its own compute engine it's
a it's really a totally separate
language is like declarative tensor
language embedded inside of Python they
compile stuff to the GPU and then fails
for no clear reason and so Chara's hides
that stuff from you you typically get an
error from inside of Karass instead of
inside of Theano lasagna takes a much
more like it's a little bit more of like
for adults like you know you know what
you're doing and and do you want to
implement something novel go ahead do it
and there are just some helper functions
inside of lasagna for common neural
network tasks so you have wrecked
by linear units and there's a all the
optimizers have their own little you
give it a piano element of some sort and
it gives you back another one that has
been extended in sort of the right way
but you have to think in terms of fiato
and build Theano functions and sort of
do everything cognizant of Theano
and so you end up writing a lot more
code and I find it somewhat more
error-prone but the plus side is that if
you want to do something novel if you
got so into the stuff that you wanted to
experiment with your own recurrent
neural networks that differ from the
standard ones it's much easier to do it
in lasagne
so the third implementation that I made
is in chain ER which is even more
verbose so chain ER does not use Theon
oh I find it to be much more debuggable
but it's the most verbose of all so the
basic logic of chain ER is actually kind
of cool so Theano you define this whole
compute graph and then you just let the
ATO figure out to do with it once it's
all defined that it runs some bulk
optimizations and then compiled some
stuff and runs it for you so the way the
trainer works is you actually you define
by running your code so at every step
you have inspectable data that's much
easier to debug and it's keeping track
of the computations that I use to
generate that data so at any point in
the process you ask it okay so now go
backwards and give me the gradient for
everything I've done up until this point
so it's much more like implementing
things in dumb pie you can actually grab
numpy arrays at intermediate states of
the computation which is the thing you
really can't do with fionna without a
lot of effort so that's nice except it's
really verbose it doesn't help you out a
lot you have to let everything kind of
from scratch so if you were particularly
averse to Theano and you wanted to
implement novel algorithms I think
chainer is a good option if you just
want stuff to work then you probably
want to just write this instead okay so
let's look at some output so after one
pass over the data set I chopped up the
the text into lengths fifty strings and
then I'm
addicting the fifty-first character from
those first 50 characters so this is
like kind of like the dumbest simplest
RNN task and so after one epic it sort
of looks like Old English you know
there's it knows that there's consonants
and vowels and they follow each other
and there's spaces and you know having
learned just from characters
it could be emitting just underscores
the whole time so I'm really impressed
with what F Fox worth of capacity but
yeah like an ASCII character I should
say how I'm generating this by the way
the way I generate is I give it a random
seed from within the text so I'm not
showing that part and then I run it over
the that seed of 50 characters it gives
me a distribution over characters at the
end I sample from that distribution
extend the string and then take the the
49 previous characters plus the one new
one and make that a new input so another
sequence that I run through the RNN then
it gives me another distribution so I
sample from that and I keep extending
the string building up this kind of
gibberish II Old English thing so that's
after one at Bach so after to outfox
it's getting better so it knows some
words her and she and said it's still
mostly nonsense but you know the betel
seat resent throw is almost like English
so skipping forward a bunch so after 10
a box so the old woman is clocked upon
his head and mais cannot run off and
Barratt 2/4 for the fisherman was that
young gray back and after 15 F Fox we
get the King came and said give me a
moon ah said the wolf the king was so
well to go out to him and after 40 F Fox
we get the bear was standing by the side
of the stream and said to him what away
into the forest the golden house if you
have been the world doing a pretty good
job and it's capturing the really
repetitive quality of these fairytales
so if you go through the text it's
constantly the King said something to
the princess and she went into the
forest and said something to a bear
it really does kind of look like this
it's a one pass over the full text file
of all Grimm's fairy tales
so each epic takes with Kerris in
lasagna it's about 500 seconds and with
chain ER it's longer it's maybe like
twelve thirteen hundred seconds yeah so
those are pretty sure trainers using a
GPU so I think if you don't use the GPU
then it takes much longer so I tried
doing this on my laptop which usually
I'm really surprised by how a MacBook
Air can sort of do anything like you
know the computers I feel like there's
some convergence where it doesn't matter
if you have like a really skimpy laptop
or like some you know huge server for
the most part I don't notice the
difference except what I'm doing deep
learning work where if you don't have a
GPU is just effectively useless I tried
one epic on my laptop waited for a day
nothing happened so I just gave up so
I'm running this all on on a server with
a think of last generation Tesla some
some beefy expensive GPU
okay so that was fairytale generation
I'm going to show a couple other tasks
you can do with this this is not at all
my work so I'm just sort of showing you
cool stuff people have done that is
nothing to do with me so one thing
that's become really popular is using
rnns for machine translation so this is
an example of the simplest approach to
doing that things have gotten pretty
complicated but the simplest idea is you
take a sentence of one language and you
summarize it down to a single vector so
the RNN reads that sentence and you take
the last vector representing that
sentence sort of a meaning summary and
then you could use another RNN to then
generate a sentence in the other
language and kind of a somewhat similar
process to how is generating those
character strings so the the decoding
RNN gives you a distribution over words
that it thinks could be a reasonable
thing to say at that point in time so if
you have this meaning vector and you've
generated no words what's the
distribution of first words you should
generate and then once you've generated
one word you have some internal state
signifying the one word you generated
and you still have the meaning vector
you're trying to decode so what's the
distribution over next words you should
generate and so you could unspool these
aren't ends and that way to then make a
whole sentence of English from German
and this actually works okay things have
gotten more interesting with attentional
mechanisms and sort of keeping track of
which parts you have in which bits of
meaning you haven't translated yet but
um this is a totally reasonable way to
do it and I think even just this like
simple idea of having encoding and
decoding RNN already was a big
improvement over the state of the art
before these things came into use so
another thing you can do is captioning
and so this is like a really cool
example of the the modularity of neural
network ideas so you can do really
high-quality object categorization and
localization with convolutional neural
networks and you have RN ends which kind
of have this sequence text generating
capacity so what if you take
examples of images that have text
captions and train them together to try
to make a to try to make a sort of joint
space of meaning over images and words
and then you could take a sort of
meaning vector of just the image and
then try to map it back into a word
space so which words seem to be related
to this image based on having examples
of sequences and images together so you
take an image in a sequence and you map
them together into some space and then
when you have one alone you can you can
find out which single words seem related
to that image or you could try to run
the RNN back and get whole sentence
descriptions of the image which seems to
work pretty well and it's like a little
bit spooky I don't know if anyone's try
to use the just the sentence to generate
the image it seems like it'd be really
spooky and then the things that I care
more about there's a lot of applications
in computational biology that are the
the field is like just catching on to
deep learning so there there's one
really high profile paper and splice
prediction and so you have DNA and when
it's transcribed into RNA it gets cut up
so which places get cut up is a hard
prediction problem there were some
really heuristic simple models for what
gets spliced I never work that well and
I think there's been one serious effort
using recurrent neural networks to
predict splice sites and that worked
much better and so other things that
people care about that haven't been
really like solved well but probably
will be solved with aren't ends are
sites of cleavage of a protein so you
have these different proteases and the
the proteosome that cut proteins up and
it's really useful to know where they do
it and right now we have is really
simple heuristics of like these amino
acids tend to be the ones that come
before a cut but it's not very
predictive so I think that those kinds
of tasks will probably be much better
served if you get a big data set of I
started with these couple proteins and
these are the peptides I could identify
afterward you could train an hour an end
to identify what the cutting sites could
be another thing that I'm working on now
is that last point
which is when you have a really long
protein fragment is it going to bind to
an MHC that presents it to the immune
system that's a little talk